So the gum's back in. Do you have a date or something? You can't even tell when I got the gum. It's tucked in my lip. You forget. I never forget. We should tell people who we are first. Or do they know by now? No, we're smart. Listen, this is our show. But Jesus, baby. I didn't know we were recording right now. I was yelling at you because we were about to record and you just put gum in your mouth. We got to get to the show. Shut up.
口香糖又嚼上了。你有约会还是怎么着？你根本看不出我什么时候嚼的口香糖。它藏在我的嘴唇里。你忘了。我从不忘记。我们应该先告诉大家我们是谁。还是说他们现在已经知道了？不，我们很聪明。听着，这是我们的节目。但是天哪，宝贝。我不知道我们现在正在录音。我刚才对你大喊大叫，是因为我们马上要录音了，而你却把口香糖放进嘴里。我们得开始节目了。闭嘴。
Spit your gum out and we'll go. Fine. There it is. Happy? Ew, don't put it behind your ear. What are you? I did and I put it on the table. This is smart less. Smart less. Smart less. Smart less.
把口香糖吐出来，我们就开始。好吧。吐出来了。满意了吗？咦，别把它粘在耳朵后面。你是什么人啊？我粘了，我还把它放在桌子上了。这是SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
I just listened to the radio this morning in the car and it posed a really good question and I kind of want to pose this to you guys. I think I know what it is. Who listens to the radio still? No. Is that the question? No, it just came on. But let me say this. Are you human or are you dancer? What does that mean? Yeah. What does it mean?
今天早上我在车里听广播，它提出了一个非常好的问题，我想把它抛给你们。我想我知道那是什么。还有谁在听广播吗？没有。是这个问题吗？不，它只是刚好播到。但让我说这个。你是人类还是舞者？那是什么意思？是啊。那是什么意思？
I don't know. It's a song by the Killers, which I like. I like the Killers a lot as a band. I feel like I'm both. I think I'm a human dancer. Is that a current band or an older band? No, no, that's a current band, granddad. I mean, you know, they've had hits. They sound nasty. The Killers are, yeah, I like the Killers.
我不知道。那是杀手乐队的一首歌，我喜欢。我非常喜欢杀手乐队这个乐队。我觉得我两者都是。我想我是一个人类舞者。那是一个当红乐队还是老乐队？不，不，那是当红乐队，老爷爷。我是说，你知道，他们有很多热门歌曲。他们听起来很糟糕。杀手乐队是，是的，我喜欢杀手乐队。
They're really good. They're really good. They don't sound friendly. Oh, I know because of the name you mean. Are you, wait, are you intimidated by the Killers? Well, I'd feel safer around, you know, me. Unicorn wings. Is there a band called Unicorn Wings? Or angel, angel, angel breath.
他们真的很棒。他们真的很棒。他们听起来不友好。哦，我知道了，因为名字的关系，你是这个意思吗？你，等等，你被杀手乐队吓到了吗？嗯，我觉得和，你知道，我在一起会更安全。独角兽之翼。有叫独角兽之翼的乐队吗？或者天使，天使，天使之息。
Angel hair? Uh-huh. That would, that would be. They don't sound real, they don't sound real rockin', but they do sound like the kind of band I want to start my day with. Maybe, remember Cherry Pie by White Snake? Well, it wasn't by White Snake.
天使发？嗯哼。那会，那会是。他们听起来不真实，他们听起来不像真正的摇滚，但他们听起来确实是我想要开启一天的那种乐队。也许，还记得白蛇乐队的《樱桃派》吗？嗯，那不是白蛇乐队唱的。
White Snake was, here I go again on my own. Cherry Pie was by Warrant. Oh, Jesus. How about that? How do you, I'm so scared that you know that. I know. You know what that reminds me of? That reminds me of that movie I want to see that you're in will where you played a,
白蛇乐队是，我要独自一人再次出发。樱桃派是Warrant乐队唱的。哦，天哪。怎么样？你怎么，我真害怕你知道那个。我知道。你知道那让我想起了什么吗？那让我想起了那部我想看你出演的电影，威尔，你在里面扮演一个，
like a Death Rock guy, like a hair band. Oh, The Rocker. Yeah, wait, didn't we have somebody on the podcast that was on that with you? We had. Was it with Gal Fnakis? Gal Fnakis was not in it, but the rock band that we, Rayne Wilson was the lead in,
像死亡摇滚乐手，像那种长发金属乐队。哦，《摇滚青春》。是的，等等，我们播客上不是有个人和你一起演过那部戏吗？我们有。是和加利·费纳基斯一起吗？加利·费纳基斯没演，但我们演的那个摇滚乐队，雷恩·威尔森是主唱，
he had been in a band that ended up becoming a huge hair band and the band was me and Freddie Armisen and Bradley Cooper. Yeah. By the way, Bradley did me the mistake of going day one. I want to have all these tattoos. I want my character to have all these tattoos. We're like, okay.
他曾在一个最终成为大型长发金属乐队的乐队里，那个乐队成员是我、弗莱德·阿米森和布莱德利·库珀。是的。顺便说一句，布莱德利犯了个错误，第一天就说，我想要所有这些纹身。我想要我的角色有所有这些纹身。我们说，好吧。
Okay, rookie. We'll see you for the three hour pre-calling them. Hair and makeup trailer. Day three, hair and makeup trailer. He's where he's there three hours early. He's like, fuck man, I really, I really missed this one up. Yeah. We got to have Bradley on the show.
好吧，菜鸟。我们三个小时后在化妆车见。第一天，化妆车。第三天，化妆车。他提前三个小时就到了。他说，该死，伙计，我真的，我真的搞砸了。是的。我们得请布莱德利上节目。
I don't know. I don't know. We can't, we can't book a star that big. We go, we got to dance a little faster first. You know? I told him, I told him. We'll have him on after we have Obama on. Yeah.
我不知道。我不知道。我们不能，我们不能预定那么大的明星。我们得先跳快一点。你知道吗？我告诉过他，我告诉过他。我们会在请到奥巴马之后请他。是的。
He's a post Obama. Post Obama booking. In order of billing. So we do billing. Well, this is your guest today. This is my guest. And my guest is kind of like the, he's the Bradley Cooper of comedy.
他是奥巴马之后的预定嘉宾。按出场顺序。所以我们按出场顺序。好吧，这是你今天的嘉宾。这是我的嘉宾。我的嘉宾有点像，他是喜剧界的布莱德利·库珀。
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa. I'll say that. We start guessing. Why don't you give us some hints? You know, we never, we never try to really guess. Okay, yeah. We don't guess. Why don't you try to give us a couple of hints.
哦，哇，哇，哇。我会这么说。我们开始猜吧。你为什么不给我们一些提示？你知道，我们从不，我们从不真的去猜。好吧，是的。我们不猜。你为什么不试着给我们几个提示。
And let's see if we can get it. The Bradley Cooper of comedy. Okay. Now, do we buzz in or do we just blurt? Our, okay. Our guest, our guest is a male. Well, because he would be the Bradley Cooper. You sound unsure.
看看我们能不能猜出来。喜剧界的布莱德利·库珀。好吧。现在，我们是按铃还是直接脱口而出？我们的，好吧。我们的嘉宾，我们的嘉宾是男性。嗯，因为他会是布莱德利·库珀。你听起来不确定。
Comedic actor slash standup. I, he's going to hate all of this, which is going to be great. Cause he's really going to, he's going to battle me on all of it. He's going to come at me hard on this. He's a standup actor. Well, he's going to make me feel foolish for A,
喜剧演员兼单口相声演员。我，他会讨厌这一切，这会很棒。因为他真的会，他会就这一切和我争论。他会在这方面对我进行猛烈抨击。他是个单口相声演员。嗯，他会让我觉得自己很愚蠢，因为A，
or preamble and B, my description of him. And you might not, Jason, that might help you guess who it is. If he's going to clown me. Somebody is going to clown you. I mean, is it cross? Is it a guy who wrote on the Ben Stiller show? Is it a guy who started one of the most impactful?
或者开场白，B，我对他的描述。而且你可能不会，杰森，那可能有助于你猜出他是谁。如果他要嘲弄我。有人会嘲弄你。我是说，是克罗斯吗？是那个在《本·斯蒂勒秀》写过剧本的人吗？是那个开启了最具影响力的人吗？
Certainly in my life, impactful comedies of all time. One of the great shows. We had his buddy on the show not too long ago. Bob Odenkirk. They created a show called Mr. Show. Well, this is David Cross. I already guessed it. The rest of the development is David Cross.
当然在我生命中，是有史以来最具影响力的喜剧之一。伟大的节目之一。我们不久前请了他的好友上节目。鲍勃·奥登科克。他们创作了一个叫《Mr. Show》的节目。好吧，这是大卫·克罗斯。我已经猜到了。剩下的发展是大卫·克罗斯。
Oh, it's David Cross. David. Woo. David. There he is. He's holding up some kind of pillow. Oh. Oh, no.
哦，是大卫·克罗斯。大卫。呜。大卫。他就在那儿。他拿着某种枕头。哦。哦，不。
Now he's making out with a. Making out with a face pillow. Yep. That listener, if you could see this Santa Claus beard on our beautiful friend. No, you actually look like Bubba Ramdas. Thank you. You know Ramdas is?
现在他在和一个。在和一个脸部枕头亲热。是的。那位听众，如果你能看到我们这位漂亮朋友脸上的圣诞老人胡子。不，你看起来其实像巴巴·拉姆·达斯。谢谢。你知道拉姆·达斯是谁吗？
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Uh-huh. God rest his soul. My legally recognized great godfather. Wow. In Rhode Island. Do you have other godparents who aren't legally recognized
嗯哼。是的。嗯哼。上帝保佑他的灵魂。我法律上认可的伟大的教父。哇。在罗德岛。你有其他法律上不认可的教父吗？
that you? Yeah. I mean, there's some that are pending, you know, and have been kind of in the pipeline for a while. Still being vetted. Yeah, I've got about 52 in Wales. Oh, wow. And in the animal whales, who've been like.
你？是的。我是说，有些还在处理中，你知道，已经在筹备中有一段时间了。还在接受审查。是的，我在威尔士有大约52个。哦，哇。在动物鲸鱼里，他们就像。
Oh, got it. They're inside. Yeah, sorry. I didn't mean the country. Oh, sorry. Well, I thought you meant the country. I was Googling the country. No, no, they're inside the bellies of large mammals.
哦，明白了。他们在里面。是的，抱歉。我不是指那个国家。哦，抱歉。好吧，我以为你是指那个国家。我刚才在谷歌搜索那个国家。不，不，他们在大型哺乳动物的肚子里。
Yeah. Sean, do you know David? Do you guys know each other at all? Yes, of course. I mean, we've ran into each other millions of times. Yeah. We had brunch. David, is that a crib behind you?
是的。肖恩，你认识大卫吗？你们认识吗？是的，当然。我是说，我们遇到过无数次。是的。我们一起吃过早午餐。大卫，你身后那是婴儿床吗？
Yes, it is. Oh, bless your heart. My daughter, she can now get out of it though. So we're in Toronto right now. She's 17. I don't know why you're still trying to keep her all boxed up. Just call it protective.
是的，是。哦，上帝保佑你。我女儿，不过她现在能从里面出来了。所以我们现在在多伦多。她17岁了。我不知道为什么你还想把她关在里面。就叫它保护吧。
I'm just looking out for her. And, you know, that's a big, scary world out there. Right. Wait, David, do you live in Toronto? Where do you? No, I'm here. My wife is working on a show up here. And because of COVID, we had to move the whole family.
我只是在照顾她。而且，你知道，外面是一个巨大而可怕的世界。对。等等，大卫，你住在多伦多吗？你在哪里？不，我在这儿。我妻子在这儿拍一部戏。因为新冠，我们不得不搬动整个家庭。
Right, because you can't go back and forth without a two week. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. You're playing Mr. Mom? Mm-hmm. Yeah. During all this?
对，因为你不能在没有两周隔离的情况下往返。是的，没错。是的。你在当全职奶爸？嗯哼。是的。在这期间？
I have been able to actually pick up even more work than my wife has. I'm very, very popular and successful. Male breastfeeding doesn't count as an occupation, David. Well, it says you. Maybe I'm the Hollywood, but. What does your wife do, David? My wife is Elizabeth Banks,
我实际上比我妻子接到了更多的工作。我非常，非常受欢迎和成功。男性母乳喂养不算职业，大卫。好吧，你说得对。也许我是好莱坞的，但是。你妻子做什么的，大卫？我妻子是伊丽莎白·班克斯，
and she has produced the Pitch Perfect movies. No way. In a couple other movies. Does her husband know that you guys are together? Yeah, yeah. My wife is Amber Tamblin. And she is, she does a lot of things, but in this. Don't plug this show she's working right now.
她制作了《完美音调》系列电影。不会吧。还有其他几部电影。她丈夫知道你们在一起吗？是的，是的。我妻子是安珀·坦布琳。她，她做了很多事情，但在这一部里。别给这节目打广告，她现在正在拍。
Don't say the name of it, because they don't deserve it. They don't deserve the plug. Really? Have you seen it? What have you been hearing? No, I'm just saying I just, until they pay us I don't want them to get the free plug.
别说名字，因为他们不配。他们不配得到广告。真的吗？你看过吗？你听到了什么？不，我只是说，直到他们付钱给我们，我不想让他们得到免费广告。
But why The Last Man is what it's called? Oh, I do. Based on a really great graphic novel. Have you ever read that? Have you ever read? No. Why The Last Man? It's really good, really good.
但为什么叫《Y染色体：末日男儿》？哦，我知道。基于一部非常棒的漫画小说。你读过吗？你读过吗？没有。为什么是《Y染色体：末日男儿》？它真的很棒，真的很好。
Sorry, all bits aside, what is the book that it's based on? It's a graphic novel. It's the letter Y, like the chromosome. Y, The Last Man. It's really good. It came out a long time ago. And you do a lot of junkets for your wife?
抱歉，撇开所有段子不谈，它基于哪本书？这是一部漫画小说。是字母Y，就像染色体一样。Y，《末日男儿》。它真的很棒。它很久以前就出来了。你为你妻子做了很多宣传活动吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I mean, that's after you guys, I jump off here, I'm doing Ted and Nadine. Sure. And then I'm doing, I'm doing Randy Quaid's From the Bunker, it's called. Okay. From the Bunker.
是的。是的，我是说，在你们之后，我跳过这里，我要去做泰德和娜丁。当然。然后我要去做，我要去做兰迪·奎德的《来自地堡》，它是这么叫的。好吧。《来自地堡》。
From the Bunker. David, what side work have you truly picked up there in Toronto while she's working? I'm on a show called Station 11, which is a sci-fi thing based on a book. I also did a movie called Eight Bit Christmas. And I did an episode of What We Do in the Shadows, which was a blast.
《来自地堡》。大卫，当她在工作时，你在多伦多真正接了什么副业？我在一个叫《第11号站》的节目里，这是一个基于书的科幻片。我还拍了一部叫《8位圣诞节》的电影。我还拍了一集《吸血鬼生活》，那真是太棒了。
And you take the baby with you or does Amber take the baby with her? Who gets the baby on the set? We have a widows walk thing up on the top of the house. She's safe up there. Yeah. And you just chain her to something that's just short enough where she doesn't go over the edge.
你带着孩子吗，还是安珀带着孩子？谁在片场带孩子？我们在房子顶上有一个寡妇走廊。她在上面很安全。是的。你只是把她拴在某个足够短的地方，让她不会掉下去。
Dude, I don't chain her. Sorry, rope. We just hide up. And it's not like a binding thing. She is attached, I don't chain her. It's a soft rope. It's a soft rope. David, tell us about,
伙计，我没拴她。抱歉，绳子。我们只是藏起来。那不是一种束缚。她被系着，我没拴她。那是一根软绳。那是一根软绳。大卫，告诉我们关于，
one of my favorite shows is Arrested Development. I just love what you did on there. So the elephant in the room for the listeners is Jason, Will and David all together were on Arrested Development. If you haven't heard us talk about it, it was the show. Yeah, make sure it's on Fox. Why don't you describe it?
我最喜欢的节目之一是《发展受阻》。我真的很喜欢你在里面的表现。所以听众们心知肚明的是，杰森、威尔和大卫都出演了《发展受阻》。如果你没听我们谈论过，那就是那个节目。是的，确保它在福克斯播出。你为什么不描述一下？
Sean, tell us who our characters were. Check the wiki page on this description. Sure. So they were all relatives on the show. Relatives, okay, good. They were all related. And so... It's been a minute.
肖恩，告诉我们我们的角色是谁。查看这个描述的维基页面。当然。所以他们都是节目里的亲戚。亲戚，好吧，很好。他们都有亲戚关系。所以……已经过去一会儿了。
What was the show about? Because it's been a minute for me. Sure. So it was just about the Bluth family. That was pretty good. Did I get that right? Question mark. That's pretty good.
这个节目是关于什么的？因为对我来说已经过去一会儿了。当然。所以它只是关于布鲁斯家族。那还不错。我猜对了吗？问号。那还不错。
Bluth and it was Jason's family. And the chaos that Jason's character had to manage. Everybody was out of control. So Jason had to keep everybody together. That sounds like you, like being dragged into Rupert Murdoch's office at news court back in 2005 on why it should be kept on the air.
布鲁斯，那是杰森的家庭。杰森的角色必须管理的混乱。每个人都失控了。所以杰森必须把每个人聚在一起。这听起来像你，就像2005年被拖进鲁珀特·默多克在新闻集团的办公室，解释为什么它应该继续播出。
And that's why it got canceled. And you're really scared that not only the show is going to get canceled, but you're going to lose your job if you don't do a good job explaining why this show is on the air. When's the last time we did that? When was the last time we shot that show?
这就是它被取消的原因。你真的很害怕不仅节目会被取消，如果你不能很好地解释为什么这个节目在播出，你还会丢掉工作。我们上次那样做是什么时候？我们上次拍那个节目是什么时候？
How long has it been? It feels like a long time, right? Are you talking about the reshoots because of how fucked up the actual shoot was? Or is it actually cute? Yeah. Was it 10 years ago? Jason's stand-in.
过了多久了？感觉过了很久，对吧？你是说因为实际拍摄有多糟糕而进行的重拍吗？还是它真的很可爱？是的。是10年前吗？杰森的替身。
Yeah, we had a lot of stand-ins. There were several. Oh, really? David, remember being up in like, where we were like Santa Clarita, and there's like all of us, and we're shooting like in this weird all-in-the-line so that we can't see Jason,
是的，我们有很多替身。有几个。哦，真的吗？大卫，记得我们在像，我们在圣克拉丽塔的时候，我们所有人都在，我们在拍那种奇怪的排成一排的戏，这样我们就看不到杰森，
and we're talking to Jason's stand-in, and we keep fucking around with Jason's stand-in. Well, what about we did that entire final season without Portia, because she wasn't available or something like that. And then we ended up doing all of her scenes on like one or two days. She was by herself just against a green screen,
我们在和杰森的替身说话，我们一直在和杰森的替身胡闹。好吧，那我们拍完最后一季时没有波西亚呢，因为她没空或者类似的原因。然后我们最终在一天或两天内拍完了她所有的戏份。她独自一人对着绿幕，
and they just cut her into everything throughout the season, right? Yeah, they just shuffled her hand. And then immediately people noticed. I mean, within hours of it. Seriously, within hours of it on. We didn't pull that off. Everyone's all over the internet going,
他们只是把她剪辑进整个赛季的所有内容里，对吧？是的，他们只是把她拼凑进去。然后人们立刻就注意到了。我是说，在播出几小时内。说真的，在几小时内。我们没能瞒过去。互联网上到处都是人说，
what the fuck's going on with the green screen? People noticed. David, let me ask you quickly, because I forget how it went down, but I remember when we were doing the pilot, you were gonna kind of do it. I remember Mitch pitched it to you, and you were like at first,
绿幕到底是怎么回事？人们注意到了。大卫，让我快速问你一下，因为我忘了它是怎么发生的，但我记得我们在拍试播集时，你本来要演的。我记得米奇向你推销它，你起初是，
is this right and tell me if I'm wrong? You were kind of hesitant at first? I didn't want to, I basically just moved to New York after nine years in LA and wanting to get out of LA and found an opportunity and just literally got a U-Haul through my stuff in it, got a sublet and then just moved. And I would deal with all the ramifications later.
这是对的吗，如果我错了请告诉我？你起初有点犹豫？我不想，我基本上在洛杉矶待了九年后刚搬到纽约，想离开洛杉矶，找到了一个机会，就真的租了一辆U-Haul，把东西扔进去，找了个转租房，然后就搬走了。我以后再处理所有的后果。
And then I was kind of settled and I just didn't want to go back to do a show that potentially could run for years and years and years. So you signed a one-year deal. You signed a series of one-year deals. No, but you did, you had like an out. You had like an... I said I'd only do it if it was part-time
然后我安定下来了，我只是不想回去拍一个可能要播好几年好几年的节目。所以你签了一份一年合同。你签了一系列一年合同。不，但你确实，你有一个退出条款。你有一个……我说过只有它是兼职我才做，
for like six episodes. And then we went to shoot the pilot, and that was the deal. And I talked to Joe and Anthony and I talked to Mitch about the character and da-da-da. And I said, okay, I'll do it under these conditions. And then during shooting the pilot, I called my then girlfriend
比如六集。然后我们去拍试播集，这就是协议。我和乔、安东尼谈过，我和米奇谈过关于角色的事，等等等等。我说，好吧，我会在这些条件下做。然后在拍试播集时，我给我当时的女朋友打电话，
and I was like, this show is amazing. This cast is amazing. I have to do it. I'm so sorry. I have to say and do this. And it's over. Can you send my U-Haul back? You're fired.
我说，这个节目太棒了。这个演员阵容太棒了。我必须做。我很抱歉。我必须留下来做这个。结束了。你能把我的U-Haul送回去吗？你被解雇了。
But David, I remember so many memories for me. I remember from the pilot, and one of them that really stuck out was we were shooting all that stuff. Lucille's penthouse, which obviously the set that we all got used to shooting on was modeled after, and it was just a function of a location. It was modeled after this suite
但是大卫，我记得我有很多回忆。我记得试播集，其中一个让我印象深刻的是我们拍了所有那些东西。露西尔的顶层公寓，显然我们都习惯拍摄的那个场景是仿照的，它只是一个地点的功能。它是仿照这个套房，
at the Ritz Carlton and Marina Del Rey. Remember we shot down there the pilot? That's where we shot the pilot. Yeah. And once we were locked into that look, that just became the look for the rest of the series. That was the only reason. It was like an available suite to shoot in.
在玛丽安德尔湾的丽思卡尔顿酒店。记得我们在那儿拍的试播集吗？那就是我们拍试播集的地方。是的。一旦我们锁定了那个外观，那也就成了该系列其余部分的外观。这就是唯一的原因。它就像一个可以拍摄的空置套房。
But I remember we were all shooting. We shot all those scenes upstairs over a few days. And we were staying at that hotel, I think too, when we were shooting. It was weird. But I remember you having a scene with Jason and we were kind of in the living room. Jason leaves and he walks into the dining room
但我记得我们都在拍摄。我们在几天内拍完了楼上所有的场景。我想我们在拍摄时也住在那个酒店。很奇怪。但我记得你和杰森有一场戏，我们在客厅里。杰森离开，走进餐厅，
and he says, Tobias, how are you doing? How's it going? And you go, it's good. And then there's just a pause. It's gonna be good. That was to me. It's going to be good. It's going to be good.
他说，托拜厄斯，你好吗？怎么样？你说，很好。然后就停顿了一下。会很好的。那是对我说的。会很好的。会很好的。
And that moment to me, I was like, fuck, this show is fucking funny. David is so fucking funny. This is so fucking... There was something about that moment that stuck out to me. And that was also when we were kind of able to improvise a little bit more during the pilot
那一刻对我来说，我想，该死，这个节目太他妈搞笑了。大卫太他妈搞笑了。这太他妈……那一刻有些东西让我印象深刻。那也是我们在试播集期间能够多一点即兴发挥的时候，
and the first, maybe half of the first season, some of that stuff would make it in and you were encouraged to do that, which was kind of fun, you know? Yeah. I want to go back to that thing you said, which was really interesting. You made a deal where you only did the first six episodes
以及第一季的前半部分，一些东西会放进去，你被鼓励这样做，这很有趣，你知道吗？是的。我想回到你说的那个非常有趣的事情。你达成了一个协议，你只拍了前六集，
or something, is that what you said? Just six, not the first six, but I didn't want to be a full-time, I didn't want to move back to LA. I was just, all I heard was like, I'm an actor and I don't want to be in something successful. No, no, I don't want to be in something that's very long.
或者类似的东西，那是你说的吗？只是六集，不是前六集，但我不想成为全职，我不想搬回洛杉矶。我只是，我听到的全是，我是个演员，我不想参与什么成功的东西。不，不，我不想参与什么很长的东西。
That's counterintuitive, yeah. I really, I mean, mentally, I had to get out of LA. I was really... I got it. And it was good for me. And leaving LA and moving to New York was, I got back in the standup and I went in a direction I had wanted to go through.
那很反直觉，是的。我真的，我是说，在精神上，我必须离开洛杉矶。我真的……我明白了。这对我有好处。离开洛杉矶搬到纽约，我重新开始做单口相声，我朝着我想去的方向前进。
And also, I knew I had to get kind of that stuff out of my system, what I spent the first couple of years in New York doing. And for my mental health, I wanted to get out of LA. Yeah, I understand. A lot of actors would be like, oh my God, there's a job. Where is it?
而且，我知道我必须把那些东西从我的系统中清除出去，我在纽约的前几年就是这么做的。为了我的心理健康，我想离开洛杉矶。是的，我明白。很多演员会说，哦天哪，有工作。在哪儿？
Okay, I'll be there, I'll be there 10 minutes early. Right, right. And then you always had that, you've always had that. Don't mock me, Will. No, no, no, no. I'm not, Jason, not everything has something to do with you for Christ's sake. No, I don't buy it.
好吧，我会去的，我会提前10分钟到。对，对。而且你一直有那个，你一直有那个。别嘲笑我，威尔。不，不，不，不。我不是，杰森，不是每件事都和你有关，看在上帝的份上。不，我不买账。
It's so sad, David, you've forgotten, but it's worse than it was before. I can't. But I wouldn't say that you've gone against the grain, but you've always stood true to kind of what you want to do. And you've always kind of done it your own way. Obviously there are things that happen and you have jobs that you have to do
太可悲了，大卫，你忘了，但它比以前更糟了。我不能。但我不会说你违背了本意，但你一直忠于你想做的事情。你一直以自己的方式做事。显然有些事情发生了，你有必须做的工作，
and I'm not gonna bring up the chipmunks. But there are, not the first one, but the one that they forced you to do, like the third one or whatever it was, which was one of the funniest. And I want to get into that story of the battle you had with that person, which was so epic. But David, when you started,
我不会提起花栗鼠。但有，不是第一部，而是他们强迫你拍的那部，比如第三部什么的，那是最有趣的之一。我想深入了解你和那个人之间的战斗故事，那真是太史诗了。但是大卫，当你开始时，
I always wondered who are the people that you liked in comedy? Who are the people that you looked up to or when you were younger, you were like, yeah, I want to kind of do that shit because you've always done things to the beat of your own drum. I mean, I was, you know, as far as like standups,
我一直想知道你在喜剧里喜欢谁？你仰慕谁，或者当你年轻时，你会说，是的，我想做那种事，因为你一直按自己的节奏做事。我是说，我是，你知道，至于单口相声，
and I think a lot of this is just because of, you know, I was in a rural part of Georgia, suburban rural area, a very heavily Southern Baptist and I was a weirdo. And I was, you know, I mean, there was the amount of like anti-Semitic shit that people just assumed was okay to say to you. And that's changed, or is that?
我想这很大程度上是因为，你知道，我在佐治亚州的一个农村地区，郊区农村，一个非常浓厚的南方浸信会地区，我是一个怪胎。而且我，你知道，我是说，人们理所当然地认为对你说反犹太主义的东西是可以的。那改变了，还是说？
I mean, I think the, where I grew up now is all, Atlanta's sprawling, you all shoot there, you know, what it's like. I mean, it's a big city now. It's a... It's the San Francisco of the South. That's what they call it. Okay, who calls it that?
我是说，我认为，我长大的地方现在全是，亚特兰大在扩张，你们都在那儿拍戏，你知道那是什么样。我是说，它现在是个大城市。它是……南方的旧金山。他们是这么叫的。好吧，谁这么叫它？
I think I've heard that. San Francisco calls it that. I've read that in the San Francisco Chronicle. It's just like five times as big as it was when I was growing up and, you know, I'm old. This was a long time ago and it was just not a good place. So you really, I, you know, got into comedy and kind of, I loved Monty Python.
我想我听说过。旧金山人这么叫它。我在《旧金山纪事报》上读到过。它只是比我长大时大了五倍，而且，你知道，我老了。那是很久以前的事了，那不是个好地方。所以你真的，我，你知道，进入了喜剧，而且，我喜欢蒙提·派森。
I would stay up, even though I couldn't physically stay up, I tried to stay up and watch SNL and any of that stuff. And I would watch stand-ups on The Tonight Show. And I was way, way, way, way, way into Andy Kaufman and it adversely influenced my early stuff. I was just a weirdo on stage, nothing like I am now. I mean, I just, it took me a long time to find my voice and figure that thing out.
我会熬夜，尽管我身体上熬不了夜，我试着熬夜看SNL和任何那种东西。我会看《今夜秀》上的单口相声。我非常，非常，非常，非常，非常迷安迪·考夫曼，它对我早期的作品产生了负面影响。我在舞台上只是个怪胎，和我现在一点也不像。我是说，我花了好长时间才找到自己的声音并弄清楚那件事。
But I was, I was like, weird for weird's sake, you know? But I was in New York, I was at the punchline at Sandy Springs and people were like, what the fuck is this? See it? You know? Right, right. I drive to Sandy Springs every single morning.
但我当时，我就是为了怪而怪，你知道吗？但我当时在纽约，我在桑迪斯普林斯的Punchline，人们就像，这他妈是什么？看到了吗？你知道吗？对，对。我每天早上都开车去桑迪斯普林斯。
Yeah, and Sandy Springs is closer to the city than where I was. I mean, I was further north than like Roswell, Alpharetta. Oh, really? Yeah, yeah. That's gorgeous in Alpharetta, horse country. Yeah, well, I mean, now it's, it's like all connected, but believe me, when I, when I was there, it was,
是的，桑迪斯普林斯离城市比我住的地方近。我是说，我比罗斯威尔、阿尔法利塔更靠北。哦，真的吗？是的，是的。阿尔法利塔很美，马场。是的，好吧，我是说，现在它，它就像连在一起了，但相信我，当我，我在那儿的时候，
there were, the, the high school hangout was McDonald's. It was like a McDonald's parking lot. That was it. There was nothing. For sure. It was one of those places. Yeah. And now, back to the show.
有，高中的聚会地点是麦当劳。就像麦当劳的停车场。就是那样。什么都没有。当然。它是那种地方之一。是的。现在，回到节目。
I've been such a fan of yours, David, since Mr. Show with you and Bob, and forgive me if this did happen, but would you guys ever do that again? Would you, have you guys ever talked about just, hey, you know what? We should go back and just do like 10 episodes or something. We did, we don't own the names. That's why when we, we did something on Netflix,
大卫，我一直是你的粉丝，自从你和鲍勃的《Mr. Show》开始，如果这真的发生了请原谅我，但你们会再做一次吗？你们，你们有没有谈过，嘿，你知道吗？我们应该回去拍个10集什么的。我们做过，我们不拥有名字。这就是为什么当我们，我们在Netflix上做了一些事情，
we did four episodes. Oh, you did? Okay. And it was called with Bob and David. Okay. Cause HBO. And there's a weird, I'm sure you witnessed this or know of it, but you know,
我们拍了四集。哦，你们拍了？好吧。它叫《鲍勃和大卫》。好吧。因为HBO。而且有一个奇怪的，我相信你目睹过或知道它，但你知道，
HBO and Netflix are like enemies. Yeah. They hate each other. They do not like each other. No. And they won't let people from, if you're on, I remember when we were doing, arrested and Tony Hale was on Veep at the time.
HBO和Netflix就像敌人。是的。他们互相憎恨。他们不喜欢对方。不。而且他们不会让来自，如果你在，我记得我们在拍《发展受阻》时，托尼·海尔当时在拍《副总统》。
Remember? Yep. And HBO was like, he can do, he can be on a total of 19 minutes. And he can't be on the, remember he couldn't be on the cover of Entertainment Weekly? Yeah. Oh my God.
记得吗？是的。HBO就像，他可以做，他总共可以出镜19分钟。而且他不能上，《娱乐周刊》的封面，记得吗？是的。哦，天哪。
That's right. Cause HBO was like, no. Cause he's, and it's like, man. Come on. Okay. But they would not let us say Mr. Show, HBO. So we, we. So to this day, they still own Mr. Show, the name?
没错。因为HBO就像，不。因为他，就像，伙计。拜托。好吧。但他们不让我们说《Mr. Show》，HBO。所以我们。所以直到今天，他们仍然拥有《Mr. Show》这个名字？
Yeah. I mean. It's a feeling like, watch this. We're going to keep this name forever. Okay. Like what? No, I don't, I don't get that sense. I don't think they care that much.
是的。我是说。感觉就像，看着。我们要永远保留这个名字。好吧。像什么？不，我没有，我没有那种感觉。我不认为他们那么在乎。
It's just sort of a blanket policy. Like, no, no, no. I guess if it becomes super successful on Netflix, then somebody worries that they'll lose their job. Like, how did you let them take this? Right, right, right. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
这只是一种一揽子政策。就像，不，不，不。我想如果它在Netflix上变得超级成功，那么有人会担心他们会丢掉工作。就像，你怎么能让他们拿走这个？对，对，对。是的。是的，是的。
Tell me about, tell me about LA and what, what it was about LA that felt kind of, it wasn't a fit for you, right? I mean, I, I try to be really fair and I've never said or even felt the, you know, oh, it's a bunch of, it's bullshit and play everybody. I don't feel that way at all. In fact, and I've said this numerous times
告诉我，告诉我关于洛杉矶，以及洛杉矶有什么让你觉得有点，它不适合你，对吧？我是说，我，我试着非常公平，我从来没说过甚至没感觉到，你知道，哦，那是一堆，那是胡扯，玩弄每个人。我一点也不那么觉得。事实上，而且我多次说过这个，
and I've cited you as, as a big part of this is the people that are born and raised in LA are some of the coolest, most grounded people I know. And it's, it's really the people who come, you know, from other places. I'm Chicago. I'm like Sean, like Sean. Or people from Toronto sometimes.
我引用你作为，作为这其中的很大一部分，在洛杉矶土生土长的人是我认识的最酷、最脚踏实地的人。而且，它，它真的是那些从，你知道，其他地方来的人。我是芝加哥人。我像肖恩，像肖恩。或者有时来自多伦多的人。
Who come in with dreams? I mean, I mean, from Canada, not, not in other places. I didn't, I didn't move to LA until I was 42. So give me a break. I lived in New York. But by the way, I just read this great article but the idea of like romanticizing in the New Yorker, I don't know if you guys have ever heard of it.
带着梦想进来的人？我是说，我是说，来自加拿大，不是，不是其他地方。我没，我直到42岁才搬到洛杉矶。所以放过我吧。我住在纽约。但顺便说一句，我刚读到这篇很棒的文章，关于在《纽约客》中浪漫化的想法，我不知道你们有没有听说过。
It's a magazine. This is well established on the show that neither Jason nor Sean ever read a book. So, but, but there was a great article about like the idea of when people wear it as a badge, you know, that they're a New Yorker, that they love New York. I'm with you on the same thing of like, and I think I did it at a certain time.
这是一本杂志。这在节目中已经确立了，杰森和肖恩从不读书。所以，但是，但是有一篇很棒的文章，关于当人们把它当作一种标志时，你知道，他们是纽约客，他们爱纽约。我和你有同样的想法，就像，而且我想我在某个时候做过。
You and I were unarrested at the same, obviously at the same time, but we would, we were both living based out of New York and we would fly and we would often fly back and forth. And there was that temptation to be like, fuck everybody from LA and fight. And as I felt the same way that you do is like, no, I know a lot of really great, smart,
你和我当时都在《发展受阻》，显然在同一时间，但我们会，我们都住在纽约，我们会飞，我们经常飞来飞去。有一种诱惑，就像，去他妈的洛杉矶的所有人，战斗。而且我感觉和你一样，就像，不，我在洛杉矶认识很多非常棒、聪明、
interesting, talented people in LA. And that notion, it's kind of like the New Yorkers you meet here in LA, older people who are like, yeah, I was born in a, you know, I'm from New Jersey. You want so badly to be identified with New York. It's okay. It's better. Okay. There's a bigger defensive posture from New Yorkers
有趣、有才华的人。那种观念，有点像你在洛杉矶遇到的纽约客，年纪大的人，他们就像，是的，我出生在，你知道，我来自新泽西。你太想被认同为纽约人了。没关系。它更好。好吧。纽约客有更大的防御姿态，
than there is a defensive posture of people from LA, right? New York is the only place where people will preface their sentences with like, well, I'm from New York and, you know, I'm from LA and we, I'm from Chicago. And we, you know, nobody does that except New Yorkers. And, you know, they're equally annoying in their own way. And what I don't care for about LA isn't about the people. It's just, it's a great city for certain personality traits.
比洛杉矶人有防御姿态，对吧？纽约是唯一一个人们会用类似的话来开头的地方，嗯，我来自纽约，而且，你知道，我来自洛杉矶，我们，我来自芝加哥。而且我们，你知道，除了纽约客没人那样做。而且，你知道，他们以自己的方式同样烦人。而且我不喜欢洛杉矶的不是关于人。它只是，它是一个适合某些性格特征的伟大城市。
And I, the things that are good about LA and attractive about LA, I don't give a shit about the ocean. I don't, I don't, the Pacific Ocean does nothing for me. I don't serve so much. Wait, you don't want to be able to surf and ski in the same day. I thought that was the big seller for you. You know, I like walking.
而且我，洛杉矶好的地方，吸引人的地方，我不在乎海洋。我不，我不，太平洋对我什么也没做。我不怎么冲浪。等等，你不想在同一天冲浪和滑雪吗？我以为那是你的大卖点。你知道，我喜欢走路。
I like density. I like community. I- So where's the most ideal place you would, and you think you would end up living? You would choose to live? Bloomington, Indiana. I'm, I'm, I'm-
我喜欢密度。我喜欢社区。我——所以你最终会住在哪里最理想？你会选择住在哪里？印第安纳州布卢明顿。我，我，我——
Oh shit. Yeah. You should have led with that. I'm a bloomer. I'm a bloomer. No, I bought a place in New York. I, I, I love New York. I've always loved it since I was a kid.
哦，该死。是的。你应该先说这个。我是个布卢明顿人。我是个布卢明顿人。不，我在纽约买了个地方。我，我，我爱纽约。我从小就一直爱它。
Good, we'd go there. I, I, I'm trying not to be like snobby about it, but New York has the things that I appreciate. And I bought a, a brownstone and, you know, we're, I set up basically roots there. I plan to live there, you know, for the rest of my life. And my daughter is going to go to school here. Which is 11 days, by the way.
很好，我们会去那儿。我，我，我试着不对此表现得势利，但纽约有我欣赏的东西。我买了一个，一个褐砂石建筑，而且，你知道，我们，我在那儿基本上扎了根。我计划住在那里，你知道，余生。而且我女儿要在这里上学。顺便说一句，还有11天。
It's 11 days. Did you just hear that, really? Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You got a cross forecast? Yeah. I feel so, dude. Oh, David.
还有11天。你刚才听到了吗，真的？是的。是的，是的，是的。你有个克罗斯预报？是的。我感觉太，伙计。哦，大卫。
Did you just get an email or something? I feel shitty being the one. Okay. Man, I've, I've had a good life. And you know, I don't, let me pull this gun out for- No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. It was a bit, it was a bit, it was a bit, it was a bit, it was a bit. I look, I feel the same way you do.
你刚才收到邮件什么的了吗？我感觉很糟糕，我是那个。好吧。伙计，我，我过得很好。而且你知道，我不，让我把这口香糖拿出来——不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。那是个段子，那是个段子，那是个段子，那是个段子，那是个段子。你看，我的感觉和你一样。
I, you know, I love New York too. And I ended up selling my, because all these New Yorkers who are listening are going to be like, you don't fucking get it. Like fuck off. I lived there for almost 25 years and I just sold my apartment, but I have a place on Long Island. I love New York too.
我，你知道，我也爱纽约。而且我最终卖掉了我的，因为所有这些正在听的纽约客会说，你他妈不懂。去他妈的。我在那儿住了快25年，我刚卖掉我的公寓，但我长岛有个地方。我也爱纽约。
It's a, for all the reasons that you said, yeah, it's, it's the best. And also- I get why people don't like it. I get it. I understand. I understand why some of that stuff is annoying people. They don't want to deal with it.
这是一个，因为你说的所有原因，是的，它，它是最好的。而且还有——我明白为什么人们不喜欢它。我明白。我明白为什么其中一些东西让人烦恼。他们不想处理它。
They'd rather have space. They'd rather have, I don't like the weather in LA. I like the weather, you know, some of the time, but I like, see, I like four seasons and I like- Yeah, I don't like sweating on Christmas. It gets, it's pretty depressing out here right around Christmas when it's 75. Yeah.
他们宁愿有空间。他们宁愿有，我不喜欢洛杉矶的天气。我喜欢天气，你知道，有时，但我喜欢，看，我喜欢四季，而且我喜欢——是的，我不喜欢圣诞节出汗。圣诞节前后这里相当令人沮丧，当气温是75度时。是的。
And David, are you still doing standup? Is it something you continue to do on a regular basis? And if not, do you miss it when you're not doing it? Well, I mean, I have to answer that because of COVID differently than I would, but- Because of what? You don't believe that. Am I pronouncing that correctly?
大卫，你还在做单口相声吗？这是你继续定期做的事情吗？如果不是，你不做的时候会想念它吗？好吧，我是说，因为新冠，我必须以不同于平常的方式回答这个问题，但是——因为什么？你不相信那个。我发音正确吗？
Survive? It's kind of, so- So- So- Company Vids. Company Video. The guys at Company Video right now are like,
幸存？它有点，所以——所以——所以——公司视频。现在的公司视频的人就像，
are you fucking kidding me? Yeah. And they just founded it in 2019. Yeah. Unbelievable. The timing of COVID. This is the fucking worst. Debbie Johnson in here right now.
你在开玩笑吗？是的。而且他们刚在2019年成立。是的。难以置信。新冠的时机。这真是他妈的最糟糕的。黛比·约翰逊现在就在这儿。
First AIDS, and now Company Video. I invested heavily in that candy. The perfect acronym. So stand up. Yeah, I always do it. It's kind of my first love and the thing that I miss more than anything when I don't get to do it. And I was actually about a,
先是艾滋病，现在是公司视频。我在那个糖果上投入了巨资。完美的缩写。所以单口相声。是的，我一直做。它算是我的初恋，也是我不做时比什么都想念的东西。而且我实际上大约，
I have like three steps of getting material ready to go out on the road again. And I was through step one, which is, kind of culling all the material before I start honing it and stuff like that. And I've been doing sets around New York and like little basements in Brooklyn that seat 99, a couple hundred people,
我有大约三个步骤准备材料再次上路。我完成了第一步，也就是，在开始磨练它之前剔除所有材料之类的。我一直在纽约周围做演出，比如布鲁克林那些能容纳99人，几百人的小地下室，
no more than that. And I was ready to, I was just about getting into phase two when COVID hit. And so I haven't done stand up. I did a couple of outdoor shows that just didn't work and... Are you gonna kind of pick back up where you were at? Oh, fuck yeah. Yeah, I have so much stuff.
不超过那个。我准备好，我刚要进入第二阶段时新冠就爆发了。所以我没做单口相声。我做了几场户外演出，只是没成功，而且……你打算从你原来的地方重新开始吗？哦，他妈的当然。是的，我有很多东西。
I'm dying to get out there. David, I love, you know, the guys know, we asked this to a lot of people because I'm obsessed with horror stories about like the word... Horror. Horror. Yeah, horror.
我渴望出去。大卫，我喜欢，你知道，大家知道，我们问过很多人这个问题，因为我痴迷于关于类似词的恐怖故事……恐怖。恐怖。是的，恐怖。
Okay, good. Horror. Because when you get slurry, it's a little, it's a different question. Yeah, Sean, you gotta enunciate. Open your mouth like this. Red leather, yellow leather. Red leather, yellow leather.
好吧，很好。恐怖。因为当你口齿不清时，这是一个有点，不同的问题。是的，肖恩，你得发音清晰。像这样张开嘴。红皮，黄皮。红皮，黄皮。
Dip at the teeth of the tongue. Wait Tobias did that once, I loved it. So horror stories about like stand up or on a movie set or your favorite horrible theater story. I love those stories. Do you have any like... David's got a million of them. Are you kidding?
舌尖轻触。等等，Tobias以前做过一次，我超喜欢。所以，讲讲关于单口喜剧、电影片场或者你最糟糕的剧院经历的恐怖故事吧。我喜欢听这些故事。你有吗……David有一大堆这种故事。你开玩笑吧？
I'm good. Yeah, I mean... Because Will talked about, mentioned earlier about the chipmunk thing and I want to know that story. Oh yeah, let's do it. Okay, so you do it, so you're doing Alvin. You do the first one.
我挺好的。是啊，我是说……因为Will刚才提到了花栗鼠的事，我想听听那个故事。哦对，讲讲吧。好，你来讲，你演Alvin。你先来第一个。
That's super successful. Yeah, the first two were fine. I mean, nobody expected it to make a billion dollars but, you know, I got paid well. I... And you've also, not only do you get paid well, I've been with you many times where people like go crazy and their kids love it
那部电影非常成功。是啊，前两部还行。我是说，没人想到它能赚十亿美元，但你知道，我片酬拿得不错。我……而且你不仅片酬高，我还多次和你一起出去，人们都为之疯狂，他们的孩子也超爱它。
and they come up to you and... Yeah, my daughter's so like... Why doesn't that guy hang out more often? You said you're friends with him. Yeah. Yeah, so this is Alvin and the Chipmunks listener. Who are now not kids anymore but I'll tell you this very, very quick little anecdote
他们会跑过来找你……是啊，我女儿总是说……那家伙为什么不多出来聚聚？你说你和他关系很好。是啊。是啊，所以这就是Alvin与花栗鼠的听众。他们现在已经不是小孩子了，但我给你们讲个非常非常简短的小轶事，
about the global popularity of Alvin and the Chipmunks. I was in Mozambique in a rural beach, like a strip of beach where you had to go through like jungle to get to the beach and it was a part of Mozambique that wasn't populated and was a long way to go to get to where they had a very few kind of huts and hot, you know, not hotels. They're nothing fancy at all.
关于Alvin与花栗鼠的全球知名度。当时我在莫桑比克的一个乡村海滩，就是那种得穿过丛林才能到达的海滩，那是莫桑比克一个人烟稀少的地方，去往那里有几间简陋小屋的地方路途遥远，不是酒店，根本算不上什么高档地方。
And it's along the Indian Ocean, just no one there. And, but no, there's no city. There's no streets. This is an hour from any kind of town. Remote, yeah. I go through and there was this, there was like this bullshitty rave thing at the... Well, first of all, hang on, how dare you?
那里沿着印度洋，一个人都没有。没有城市，没有街道。离最近的城镇都要一个小时。很偏僻，没错。我走过去，那里有个……怎么说呢，有个烂糟糟的狂欢派对……等等，首先，你竟敢这么说？
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. You have a problem with glow sticks in your teeth? Come on. And my, do I have a problem with glow sticks in my sand? And so I was like, this, fuck this place. So let's see if there's anything. And I walk like half a mile down the beach
是啊。是啊，是啊。你对牙齿上的荧光棒有意见？得了吧。还有我，我对沙滩上的荧光棒有意见吗？所以我当时想，去他的这个地方。看看还有没有别的地方。我沿着海滩走了半英里，
to another outcropping of, you know, hot places. And I walk in and there's a, you know, probably a woman in her like late thirties, early forties. And like, hi, do you speak English? And he looks up and she goes, Alvin in the chipmunks. I'm like, oh my God, that's crazy. You should have, you should have stead, stead fastly. You should have, are you like, what are you talking about?
到了另一个有……你知道，有旅店的地方。我走进去，有个大概三十多岁、四十出头的女人。我说，嗨，你会说英语吗？她抬头看着我，然后说，Alvin与花栗鼠。我说，天哪，太疯狂了。你应该……你应该坚定地……你应该，你是说，你在说什么？
Yeah. Look lady, I'm not here to talk about my career. I'm not working right now. I'm not working right now. You want to take a photo real quick? Oh my God. So it was a huge movie. So it's a huge movie.
是啊。听着，女士，我不是来谈我的职业生涯的。我现在没在工作。我现在没在工作。你想快速拍张照吗？天哪。所以那是一部大电影。所以那是一部大电影。
You do the first couple. The third one you were working on, David and I, Sean, David and I did a show over in the UK that David created called the increasingly poor decisions of Todd Margaret. Yeah, I love that. And we did two seasons or three. I can't remember.
你演了前几部。第三部你正在拍的时候，David和我，Sean，David和我当时在英国做了一个节目，是David创作的，叫《Todd Margaret越来越糟糕的决定》。是啊，我喜欢那个。我们做了两季还是三季？我不记得了。
We did three, but this was happening during the second. During the second. And you were, you were in the middle of writing the second one. Yeah. You had like all these hard dates to write it and then production and shoot. We were in pre-production. We had already started pre-production.
我们做了三季，但这事发生在第二季期间。在第二季期间。你当时正写到第二季中间。是啊。你有所有那些必须完成的硬性截止日期，要写剧本，然后是制作和拍摄。我们当时在前期制作。我们已经开始了前期制作。
And, and, you know, obviously you guys know this, this affects, there's a domino effect that would affect, you know, up to a hundred people who are, you know, cast and crew and all kinds of people if you, anyway. So yes, I was contractually obligated to do the third one. We had been asking for nine months. I'd say every seven to 10 days, am I going to have to be in it because
而且，你知道，显然你们都知道这一点，这会产生影响，会产生多米诺骨牌效应，影响到一百个人，包括演员、剧组人员等等，如果你……总之。所以是的，我合同上有义务去拍第三部。我们已经问了九个月了。我大概每七到十天就问一次，我必须得参演吗？因为
of the Todd Margaret situation? And we don't know, we don't think so. Maybe, yes, there's a possibility. No, it doesn't look like it. Well, it was a strong possibility. You know, just constantly changing. And then we got kind of a enough of a go ahead that doesn't look like you're going to be in it.
Todd Margaret的情况？他们说我们不知道，我们觉得不用。也许吧，有可能。不，看起来不用。好吧，这可能性很大。你知道，一直在变。然后我们得到了一个大概的答复，看起来你不用参演了。
Okay. So I go to London and, you know, start setting up. And me and Mark Chappell, who you know well, and Sean Pye, we start writing. We've got the production offices. We're in pre-production. This is right before Christmas and my wife, who was not my wife at the time, was over there.
好吧。所以我去了伦敦，开始筹备。我和Mark Chappell（你们很熟），还有Sean Pye，我们开始写剧本。我们有了制作办公室。我们在做前期制作。这就在圣诞节前夕，我妻子（当时还不是我妻子）也在那边。
We're, I remember exactly where we were. We were in Harrods and my phone rang and it was my manager and I answer it. I go, hi, David, I have, and then list everybody on my team, right? You know, I have him and Jason and then the Harris and then and I know when you, when your whole team calls, it's one of only two things.
我们……我记得很清楚我们在哪。我们在哈罗德百货，我的电话响了，是我经纪人打来的，我接了。我说，嗨，David，我有……然后列举了我团队里的每个人，对吧？你知道，我有他和Jason，还有Harris，我知道当你的整个团队打电话来时，只有两种可能。
It's either really good news or really bad news. Yeah. And I go, okay. And I motion to Amber. I go, I got to take this outside and walk outside. And then the very first thing I hear is, are you sitting down? And I'm like, I just know it's bad.
要么是天大的好消息，要么是天大的坏消息。是啊。我说，好吧。我向Amber示意。我说，我得出去接个电话，然后走到外面。我听到的第一句话是，你坐下了吗？我当时就觉得不妙。
I'm like, okay. You said, you think it's easier to get a seat at Harrods on a Saturday? And they tell me that not only am I going to be in the third chipmunks. Remember, this is shortly before Christmas. Not only am I going to be in the third chipmunks, I'm featured heavily in it.
我说，好吧。你说，你觉得在周六的哈罗德百货找个座位容易吗？他们告诉我，不仅我得去拍第三部花栗鼠。记住，这离圣诞节没几天了。不仅我得去拍第三部花栗鼠，而且我的戏份还很重。
Also, I need to be in Hawaii where it's shooting for rehearsals on January 3rd, I think it was. And I'm freaking out. And they're all anticipating me freaking out and they're telling me how awful they've been and how they said I couldn't do it because, and they go, well, we'll just sue them for breach of contract and blah, blah, blah.
而且，我需要在1月3日（我想是那天）赶到夏威夷参加排练。我当时快疯了。他们都预料到我会疯掉，他们告诉我他们有多糟糕，他们之前怎么说我不用去，因为……他们说，好吧，我们就起诉他们违约，诸如此类。
And keep in mind, I was nothing but professional. I think I elevated the part in the movies. I added all my stuff. Totally, oh, you've got your ass. And so I didn't know where this was coming from. It was really not cool. And obviously explained all the things about, I'm in production, this is going to affect 100 people.
记住，我一直表现得非常专业。我觉得我提升了电影里的角色。我加了很多自己的东西。完全是，哦，你真是……所以我不知道这事是从哪冒出来的。这真的很不地道。显然我解释了所有关于我正在制作中的情况，这会影响到100个人。
We can't do this. I can't even be there. I would have to go to New York to get my stuff and then fly to Hawaii. I have to go home first. I don't even have anything. I can't. 30 hours of flying.
我们不能这么做。我甚至没法去那儿。我得先回纽约拿我的东西，然后再飞往夏威夷。我得先回家。我什么都没有。我不能。30个小时的飞行。
But the kicker is, tell our listener what your basic costume is going to be. Right, so. This is great. So, well, this is kind of a separate issue, but so yeah, I'm in a Pelican mascot outfit. Completely unrecognizable. You're inside a mascot suit.
但最绝的是，告诉我们的听众你基本的戏服是什么。对，所以。这太棒了。所以，好吧，这是个单独的问题，但是的，我穿着一套鹈鹕吉祥物服装。完全认不出来。你穿在吉祥物套装里。
So you can't even tell it's him. That's hilarious. He's in a... But I think you guys are conflating two different stories. The other part of this, once we figured it out and I'm like, we had to put it on hold, and it was just really awful for all the production folks and the writers and the cast who had been cast in London.
所以你甚至看不出那是他。太搞笑了。他在一个……但我认为你们把两个不同的故事混在一起了。这事的另一部分是，一旦我们弄清楚了，我说，我们不得不暂停，这对所有制作人员、编剧和在伦敦选好的演员来说真的很糟糕。
Todd Margaret. It's for Todd Margaret. Chappy took it really hard. Poor chap. Mark Chappell. Chappy took it really hard. You got really chapped. Well, Chappy, and we should just stop the podcast
Todd Margaret。那是为了Todd Margaret。Chappy受打击很大。可怜的家伙。Mark Chappell。Chappy受打击很大。你真的很生气。好吧，Chappy，我们应该在某个时候暂停一下播客，
at one point to say that Mark Chappell, our good friend, he's a very sensitive fellow. And just our thoughts go out to him today. Okay. Keep going. Sorry. Rest in peace, Mark. Wait.
说一下Mark Chappell，我们的好朋友，他是个非常敏感的人。我们今天向他表示慰问。好吧。继续。抱歉。安息吧，Mark。等等。
Oh, he's gone? Not yet. Not yet. Not yet. Mark, do not rest in peace. No, not dead. I just mean, I want him to rest peacefully. Okay, well, that's nice.
哦，他走了？还没。还没。还没。Mark，不要安息。不，没死。我只是说，我希望他能平静地休息。好吧，那是个不错的想法。
That's a nice sentiment. That's sweet. Okay. So, yeah. So then we work it out. I'm like, there's nothing to rehearse. And they're like, and they're just making excuses. They're being really, really mean and petty and vindictive
那是个不错的感触。真贴心。好吧。所以，是的。然后我们解决了。我说，没什么好排练的。他们说……他们只是在找借口。他们真的很刻薄、很小气、很报复心强，
for what reason I don't know. Just blindly exercising their option. Like, no, we own him, so we want him for the run of the production. We'll decide what days he works. Yeah. Yeah, and they, but they were like, we need to get his sizes.
为了什么原因我不知道。只是盲目地行使他们的选择权。就像，不，我们拥有他，所以我们要在整个制作期间占用他。我们会决定他哪天工作。是啊。是啊，他们说，我们需要量他的尺寸。
I'm like, haven't changed. It's the same shoe size. I'm in a mascot outfit, guys. Part three. I'm in a Pelican mascot outfit. Those sizes don't apply. What are you talking about? I don't need to rehearse.
我说，没变。还是同样的鞋码。我穿着吉祥物套装，伙计们。第三部。我穿着鹈鹕吉祥物套装。那些尺寸不适用。你在说什么？我不需要排练。
I mean, everything I do is on green screen anyway. What are you talking about? And so we eventually got him to let me go back to New York to at least dump my stuff off and get new clothes to bring to Hawaii and Vancouver where the film was finished. But what you were referring to was two, and this is worse, this is, I don't know if anybody's
我是说，我做的一切反正都是在绿幕前完成的。你在说什么？所以我们最终让他们让我回纽约，至少把我的东西放下，拿些新衣服带到夏威夷和温哥华，电影就是在那里拍完的。但你刚才提到的是第二部，这更糟，这是……我不知道有没有人
ever been on a cruise, cruise ship. No, I try to. Sean, Sean, that's where you started, right? Oh, yeah. That's where, Hollywood days, Hollywood ways. Hi, I'm Sean Hayes with Hollywood Hayes Ways. Oh, you've seen my show. Thank you.
坐过游轮。没有，我试过。Sean，Sean，那是你开始的地方，对吧？哦，是的。那是……好莱坞的日子，好莱坞的方式。嗨，我是Sean Hayes，好莱坞Hayes方式。哦，你看过我的节目。谢谢。
Welcome to the carnivals, relaxathon. You haven't been on a cruise, but you have cruised. Yeah. Sorry, those are, yes. 10 to 12 every night. Every night? Yeah, yeah. And why just 10 to 12?
欢迎来到嘉年华，放松马拉松。你没坐过游轮，但你“巡游”过。是啊。抱歉，那些是，是的。每天晚上10点到12点。每天晚上？是啊，是啊。为什么只在10点到12点？
Because that's when they're out, that's when everybody's out. You gotta pack up early, I guess. Yeah, I gotta make my head work. He's very organized, look at his shelf, he's very organized. He also works real fast. He does work fast and hard.
因为那是他们出来的时候，那是每个人都出来的时候。我想你得早点收拾好。是啊，我得让我的头脑运转起来。他很有条理，看他的架子，他很有条理。他工作也很快。他确实工作又快又努力。
By the way, nobody works harder and faster than Sean Hayes, Sean will call you go, like, we have five things to discuss, we have to do, but it has to be done in the next 30 seconds. You're like, hang on a second, man. Anyway, so David, you get to. That is me.
顺便说一句，没有人比Sean Hayes工作更努力、更快，Sean会打电话给你说，我们有五件事要讨论，我们必须做，但必须在接下来的30秒内完成。你会说，等一下，伙计。总之，David，轮到你了。那是我。
So there's two weeks where they're shooting on a cruise ship, the Carnival Dream, I believe, at that point in time, the second largest cruise ship out on the seas. And. Stop bragging. So as scripted, the Pelican outfit is on the entire time for the fits that take place on the cruise ship.
所以有两周时间他们是在游轮上拍摄的，嘉年华梦想号，我相信当时是海上第二大游轮。而且。别吹牛了。所以按照剧本，鹈鹕套装在游轮上拍摄的戏份里一直穿着。
And it's an actual cruise that you guys are shooting on. Oh, here's, yeah, there are so many digressions here because they did not tell the people on the cruise ship that they were shooting and they would, you know, section off. And I had a whole like PowerPoint presentation that I would do in my standup where I had images and I did it to Samuel Barber's Adagio for Strings.
而且你们是在一艘真正的游轮上拍摄的。哦，这里，是的，这里有很多离题的地方，因为他们没有告诉游轮上的人他们在拍摄，他们会，你知道，划出区域。我曾经有一个完整的PowerPoint演示文稿，我在单口喜剧里做过，我有图片，我是配着Samuel Barber的《弦乐柔板》做的。
Yes. And that would play while I play the slides and it did it like Ken Burns style. And then you would see the real people, the patrons of the cruise ship. And then you'd see the hot extras that they brought in to be on the cruise ship. Right, right.
是的。当我播放幻灯片时，那音乐就会响起，就像Ken Burns风格一样。然后你会看到真实的人，游轮上的乘客。然后你会看到他们请来的火辣临时演员，让他们在游轮上。对，对。
The disparity was glaring. The disparity is quite interesting. And let me guess, it probably wasn't cold on this Hawaii cruise while you're inside this Pelican fluffy mascot outfit too, right? Oh, Ozarks. That's where I am. Yeah, yeah.
这种差异非常明显。这种差异很有趣。让我猜猜，你在夏威夷这艘游轮上穿着这套毛茸茸的鹈鹕吉祥物套装时，肯定不冷吧，对吧？Ozarks。我就是在那儿。是啊，是啊。
Yeah, yeah. Okay. This has been bugging me and bugging you. Oh, you've seen it? Have you checked it out? I've seen the ad. It's very blue. It's a dark, very blue.
是啊，是啊。好吧。这事一直困扰着我，也困扰着你。哦，你看过吗？你看了吗？我看了广告。非常蓝。那是深色，非常蓝。
Are you? That's your TV setting. I get that a lot. Everybody does not calibrated their television correctly. It's actually Amber. It's very Amber. All right, back to the show. David, I want to ask you one last question if you would.
你是吗？那是你的电视设置。我经常遇到这种情况。每个人都没有正确校准他们的电视。其实是琥珀色。非常琥珀色。好了，回到节目。David，如果你愿意，我想问你最后一个问题。
You, I feel like you were one of the first people that I know who does what we do, who went kind of oftentimes people bring shows or formats from Europe, specifically the UK and bring them to America and generally make them worse, try to remake them or whatever. You're one of the first people that I knew who kind of went the other way early on.
我觉得你是我们认识的人中，第一个做我们这行的人，经常有人把节目或模式从欧洲，特别是英国带到美国，通常会把它们改得更糟，试图翻拍它们什么的。你是第一个我认识的，很早就反其道而行之的人。
You were, I remember when we were doing Todd Margaret, you called and you were like, hey, I'm working on this thing with these guys, you know, on this pilot at the time, writing this pilot, we did a, remember we did a table read one year and then the next year shot the pilot and then the next year shot the first season
你是，我记得我们在做Todd Margaret的时候，你打电话说，嘿，我正在和这些人做这个东西，你知道，当时在写这个试播集，我们做了一个，记得我们有一年做了剧本围读，然后第二年拍了试播集，然后第三年拍了第一季，
with the Russos, but you kind of had the idea to go over there. Like you identified what that they, they were going to give you a green light, that they got your sensibility or that that was just a whole untapped. Mark, it was unusual. You kind of did it in reverse.
和Russo兄弟一起，但你当时有一种去那边的想法。就像你认定了他们会给你开绿灯，他们懂你的感性，或者那是一片完全未开发的领域。Mark，这很不寻常。你算是反着来的。
Well, yeah, I had, I didn't have that much to do with it though. It was, it was Clealia and Jane who approached me. They were doing stand-up actually. And, and they came to one of the shows and said, you know, do you want to do something for, I think it was with channel four. Yeah. I was like, I was just done the show
嗯，是的，我其实没怎么参与。是Clealia和Jane找到我的。她们当时在做单口喜剧。她们来到其中一场演出，说，你知道，你想为……我想是Channel 4做点什么吗？是啊。我当时刚做完节目，
and we were drinking and I was like, yeah, whatever. You know, they gave me a card. Okay, thanks. You seem like nice ladies. And I didn't even think about it for like two or three days later. And I was like, hey, wait, I should do something. That, that lady gave me her TV card.
我们在喝酒，我说，行啊，随便。你知道，她们给了我一张名片。好吧，谢谢。你们看起来是好女士。我甚至两三天都没想过这事。然后我想，嘿，等等，我应该做点什么。那位女士给了我她的电视名片。
And so they were the ones who kind of had the idea of doing a co-production and then doing it, you know, with channel four. I don't know if they had a deal or not, but it was, it was really their idea. And I should say it's now it's Merman Productions, which is hugely successful. Sharon Horgan and the amount.
所以她们是那种有想法做联合制作，然后做它，你知道，和Channel 4合作的人。我不知道她们当时有没有合同，但这确实是她们的主意。我应该说，现在是Merman Productions，非常成功。Sharon Horgan和……
Yeah. And do you feel, do you feel, can you take credit for Sharon Horgan's career? Do it right now. Absolutely. Absolutely. She wouldn't be nowhere without me. She wouldn't have done for prior to me meeting her.
是啊。你觉得，你觉得你能为Sharon Horgan的职业生涯邀功吗？现在就说。绝对。绝对。没有我她哪也去不了。在我认识她之前她什么都没做。
I can't wait for the email from her. David, you just reminded me of something when you were talking about drinking. I remember us partying just a little bit back in the arrested days. And you mean when you climbed the lamppost? I don't remember that. Remember that night?
我等不及要看她发来的邮件了。David，你刚才提到喝酒让我想起了一些事。我记得我们在《发展受阻》时期聚会过一点点。你是说你爬上路灯柱的时候？我不记得了。记得那天晚上吗？
I remember that. Well, wait, what were you there? Hang on. No, I left earlier because it was getting, we left, we left somebody's house and it got bad. And then I was like, fuck this, cause you guys were getting too drunk. And then...
我记得那个。等等，你在场吗？等等。不，我走得早，因为情况变得……我们离开了某人的家，情况变糟了。然后我说，去他的，因为你们喝得太醉了。然后……
Wait, what are you talking about? Are you being serious about a lamppost? Yeah. I remember I had Jason's belt for like a year. Yes. And we, the whole idea was we were gonna wait years to give it to you. And then we just sort of forgot it.
等等，你在说什么？你是认真的关于路灯柱吗？是啊。我记得我拿了Jason的皮带大概一年。是的。我们当时的想法是我们要等几年再还给你。然后我们就忘了。
I have no recollection of a lamppost. What are you talking about? What happened on the lamppost? David, tell him. David, you climbed up a lamppost? No, you did. You did, dude. I swear on my kid's life,
我完全不记得什么路灯柱。你在说什么？路灯柱上发生了什么？David，告诉他。David，你爬上了一个路灯柱？不，是你。是你，伙计。我以我孩子的生命发誓，
I don't remember what you're talking about. I don't, I just remember being really... Impressed with my climbing skills? Yeah. That's what it is. No, I just remember the next day David going, I said, did it get worse after I left? And David was like, well, at one point
我不记得你在说什么。我不记得，我只记得当时非常……对我的攀爬技巧印象深刻？是啊。就是这样。不，我只记得第二天David说，我说，我走后情况变糟了吗？David说，嗯，有一次
we were trying to pull Jason down off a lamppost. And I was like, oh, okay. It was in front of Laura Stupskers apartment. We were over at Laura Stupskers and I don't know what made you climb up the lamppost but you climbed up. It was like a big one. It was like not, you know.
我们试图把Jason从路灯柱上拉下来。我说，哦，好吧。那是在Laura Stupsker的公寓前。我们在Laura Stupsker家，我不知道是什么让你爬上了路灯柱，但你爬上去了。那是个很大的路灯柱。不是那种，你知道。
Sounds dangerous. Was I in danger? Yeah. What was I doing up there? Was I trying to saving a cat? Mainly Coke. Honestly, Jason, I think that the tiniest little flake of Coke
听起来很危险。我有危险吗？是啊。我在上面干什么？我在救猫吗？主要是可卡因。老实说，Jason，我觉得最微小的一点点可卡因
came off of your hand. The wind took it and it was up on the pole and you were just, that was it. You were. That's the last of it. I'll get it. But my question is, my life has changed significantly
从你手上掉下来了。风把它吹走了，它落在了杆子上，你就，就是那样。你就是。那是最后一点了。我去拿。但我的问题是，我的生活发生了巨大的变化
since I have procreated and gotten married. My question is to you, has your life changed significantly since your sweet, sweet baby little girl and big, big baby girl? Yeah. Very much so. I only do Coke once a week now.
自从我生了孩子并结婚后。我的问题是，你的生活在你的甜心小宝贝女儿和那个大宝贝女儿出生后发生了巨大变化吗？是啊。非常大。我现在每周只吸一次可卡因。
And I- Good for you. Good for you, David. Moderation. Good. I don't do anything anymore. I mean, I still drink, but not excessively. And I don't want to.
我……为你高兴。为你高兴，David。适度。好。我现在什么都不做了。我是说，我还是喝酒，但不酗酒。我也不想。
I don't have the desire. No, of course. You want to get up early and you want to be with your family. Yeah. I mean, that was part of it. It's like being kind of hungover and I think it was Amber's turn
我没有那种欲望。不，当然。你想早起，你想和家人在一起。是啊。我是说，那是其中的一部分。就像宿醉一样，我想那天轮到Amber
to be with her in the morning. But you get up late and like, what am I doing? This is crazy. I remember one time, years ago, I hurt my knee. We were in New York and I hurt my knee doing something.
早上陪她。但你起得很晚，就像，我在干什么？这太疯狂了。我记得有一次，几年前，我伤了膝盖。我们在纽约，我因为做某事伤了膝盖。
And I called David and I said, I don't know what to do. My knee hurts and you go, oh, I got a couple of things that you could probably help. And I go, really? And he goes, yeah. So I was in the West Village.
我给David打电话说，我不知道该怎么办。我膝盖疼，你说，哦，我有几样东西可能有用。我说，真的吗？他说，是啊。所以我当时在西村。
And so like I went over to his apartment in the East Village and he just like, in his hand, this is like 2004. He's like, in his hand, he's just got a bunch of loose stuff. He's like, I think this might be something. And I think this might be something.
所以我去了他在东村的公寓，他手里，这是2004年左右。他手里拿着一堆散装的东西。他说，我觉得这可能是个什么。我觉得这可能是个什么。
I was pretty bad. I do not, it's nothing I'm proud of. And I don't, I don't. I took it. I took it. And the knee felt great.
我当时挺糟糕的。这不是我引以为傲的事。我也不……我拿了。我拿了。膝盖感觉好多了。
David, what's the worst that happened to you when you were under the influence of something? Were you ever arrested for being drunk or anything? I had a DUI that was knocked down to whatever a DUI is. Knocked down to a hard partying. Yeah. Yeah. He was just hard partying.
David，你在受某种影响时发生的最糟糕的事情是什么？你有没有因为喝醉或什么而被捕过？我有个酒驾记录，被降级成了……不管酒驾是什么。降级成了狂欢。是啊。是啊。他只是狂欢。
I spent the night in jail in LA, locked up with like a hundred others. That was brutal. Really? Wait, what was that like? Spending the night with a hundred, I would not do well with that. It was fucking awful.
我在洛杉矶的监狱里过了一夜，和大概一百个人关在一起。那太残酷了。真的吗？等等，那是什么感觉？和一百个人过夜，我可受不了。那真是太糟糕了。
Let me tell you that initially I was smiling. I thought this is kind of, I was in the little, the area they put you in with like, it's smaller and there's like four or five other guys, right? While they're processing everything, you can see all the cops and they're, I don't know if you've ever been down there.
我告诉你，起初我还在笑。我想这有点……我当时在他们把你放进去的那个小区域，它更小，还有四五个其他家伙，对吧？当他们处理一切时，你可以看到所有的警察，他们……我不知道你有没有去过那里。
It's a big, big, big room. It looks like the DMV and then there's little cells, they put you in, there were a couple of other guys in there. And also I was on a date. I was on a first date, so I had like a nice sweater. You had a nice sweater on. I had a nice sweater. A sweater set.
那是一个很大很大的房间。看起来像车管所，然后有小牢房，他们把你关进去，里面还有几个家伙。而且我当时在约会。我在第一次约会，所以我穿了一件漂亮的毛衣。你穿了一件漂亮的毛衣。我穿了一件漂亮的毛衣。毛衣套装。
I had some product in my beard. And I was, I really stupidly, naively was like, this is fun. This will be a good story that I'll get out of here. There's, you know, I'm not drunk. This is fine, whatever. And I'm in there for maybe, maybe 45 minutes and the guy, you know,
我的胡子里还抹了点产品。我当时非常愚蠢、天真地想，这很有趣。这会是个好故事，我会从这里出去的。这里有，你知道，我没喝醉。这没关系，随便吧。我在里面待了大概，大概45分钟，那个家伙，你知道，
there's like double glass things into another room. And this guy comes up, I'm like looking out, this guy walks up and just spits on, you know, on his side of the glass at me. And I'm like, oh, geez, that's not very nice. Me. And then maybe, and I'm like talking to these guys too, like what are you in for, you know, whatever.
有双层玻璃通往另一个房间。这个家伙走过来，我看着外面，这个家伙走过来，就在玻璃的那一边对着我吐口水。我说，哦，天哪，那不太友好。我。然后也许，我也在和这些家伙说话，比如你是因为什么进来的，你知道，随便。
And then I think I'm completely under the illusion that I'm going to be let out any minute now. And they kind of announced my name. They opened the door. I go, yeah, okay. See you. See you guys. And they leave me down, not towards the desk,
然后我想我完全处于一种幻觉中，以为我随时会被放出去。他们叫了我的名字。他们打开门。我说，是啊，好吧。再见。再见伙计们。他们带我走的不是朝向柜台，
but leave me down this hallway. Wrong way. And the fluorescent lights and the, you know, puke green thing. And I'm like, huh, what? And they're like, pick a mattress, pick a pillow. You're like, there's literally these like sheets that there are rubbery things that are as thin as my pinky
而是带我走进了这条走廊。走错路了。还有荧光灯和那个，你知道，呕吐绿色的东西。我说，哈，什么？他们说，选个床垫，选个枕头。你就像，这些床垫简直就是像橡皮一样的东西，薄得像我的小指头，
and just kind of a hard pillow thing. I'm like, wait, what do you, what is, what's going on? And they take me down about a, you know, another eight things turn left here to walk on this side, don't go on that side, stay on this side, walk down here. And then they open up this cell with probably, I'm going to guess like 60 other guys, a toilet, you know, just a toilet right there and they get to the wall.
还有一个硬枕头。我说，等等，你在，这是怎么回事？他们带我走了大概，你知道，另外八个转弯，这边走，不要走那边，待在这边，走这边。然后他们打开了这个牢房，里面大概有，我猜大概60个其他家伙，一个马桶，你知道，就在那儿，他们走到墙边。
And I, You immediately went and took a dump. That would be a strong move. If you walk in and be like, I started to do a set. Like I was like, yo, yo, wait, David, by the way, by the way, David, you did a night in prison, which is bad.
而我，你立刻就去拉屎了。那将是一个强硬的举动。如果你走进去，就像，我开始表演了。就像我当时想，哟，哟，等等，David，顺便说一句，顺便说一句，David，你在监狱里过了一夜，这很糟糕。
And, but Jason, tell him one time at the Golden Globes, he had to sit in the upper level. Oh, yeah. He wasn't even, he was in the second. You remember? At what point did they take your cardigan from you? Um, you know what they, they let me keep it. They thought I looked cute in it.
但是Jason，告诉他有一次在金球奖上，他不得不坐在上层。哦，是的。他甚至不在，他在第二层。你记得吗？他们什么时候拿走了你的开衫？嗯，你知道他们，他们让我留着。他们觉得我穿起来很可爱。
A lot of winks and a lot of winks. A lot of heavy winks. A lot of winks. I love the strong move to go take a dump real quick, given a hard luck. Immediately. Yeah. And never, and never break eye contact with everybody.
很多眨眼，很多眨眼。很多沉重的眨眼。很多眨眼。我喜欢那个去拉屎的强硬举动，考虑到运气不好。立刻。是啊。而且永远，永远不要和大家断开眼神交流。
Yeah. Guys, you know, you don't want to be over here. That guy is psycho. That guy's a fucking psycho. Wow. So how long ago was that, David? Like don't, and don't say a year ago. No, no, I was living in LA. That would have been like 95 or something like that.
是啊。伙计们，你知道，你们不想待在这边。那个家伙是疯子。那个家伙是个疯子。哇。所以那是多久以前的事了，David？比如不要说一年前。不，不，我当时住在洛杉矶。那大概是95年左右。
Oh, so like, like Mr. Show time. I was like, maybe Mr. Show, we've done one seat, you know, did four episodes or something like that. It was way, way, way early. Did you get any sleep that night in the, in the lockout? No, but they also do this thing where they blasted a, a CDC and they kept the lights on. And then I don't know what time I got out.
哦，所以就像，《Mr. Show》时期。我当时就像，也许《Mr. Show》，我们做了一季，你知道，做了四集什么的。那是很早很早以前。那天晚上你在拘留所里睡着了吗？没有，但他们还做了一件事，他们播放CDC，而且灯一直亮着。我不知道我什么时候出来的。
It was early, it was probably like 9 30 in the morning, but I did the classic thing, not potentially I got out and, you know, the light, the LA sun was so harsh and I'd been inside. I did that, the classic like, you know, with the sun streaming through your finger. I can't see. I can't.
很早，大概是早上9点半，但我做了那个经典动作，我出来的时候，你知道，洛杉矶的阳光太刺眼了，我一直在里面。我做了那个经典动作，你知道，阳光透过你的手指。我看不见。我不能。
Hale the taxi, was somebody there to pick you up? Or did you get in the cab? No, I think I pulled my, I think I had to pull my car over. So my car was where, in fact, you know, I don't know if this will ring about downtown. It was like a fountain with really, a brightly colored flashing.
叫了出租车，有人去接你吗？还是你上了出租车？不，我想我把车停在路边了。所以我的车在哪，事实上，你知道，我不知道这会不会让你想起市中心。那是一个有非常明亮彩色闪烁的喷泉。
Then I got the DUI cause I did a UE. There was nobody on the road. I just was with a girl like, oh, let's check that out. Let's go over to that fountain and just kind of did a U turn and you're okay. Did you ever have another date with that girl? No. No.
然后我酒驾了，因为我做了个U型转弯。路上没人。我只是和一个女孩在一起，哦，去看看那个。去那个喷泉看看，然后就做了个U型转弯，你没事吧。你和那个女孩还有过第二次约会吗？没有。没有。
No. How about that? Shocker. Yeah. She didn't even pick you up the next morning? No, it wasn't, it was, we just weren't meant to be dating. Clearly.
没有。那怎么样？震惊吧。是啊。她第二天早上甚至没去接你？没有，不是，我们只是不适合约会。很明显。
It was not about the. You never sent you a real clear message on that one. Sean, when was the last time you were incarcerated? Yeah. Don't lie. What time is it? Oh, wow. Have you ever been locked up?
这不是关于。你从来没在那件事上给你发过明确的信息。Sean，你上次被监禁是什么时候？是啊。别撒谎。现在几点了？哦，哇。你被关起来过吗？
Wait, wait, I didn't know you could do sound effects. Sean, have you been locked up? I was in college. I stole a turkey sandwich from a 7-Eleven and I had no money and I stole it and outside I was throwing the tomatoes at cars before I eat it. I was completely intoxicated. It was just delirious with hunger.
等等，等等，我不知道你会做音效。Sean，你被关起来过吗？我在大学的时候。我从7-Eleven偷了一个火鸡三明治，我没钱，我偷了它，在外面我吃之前还在往车上扔西红柿。我完全喝醉了。饿得神志不清。
Yeah. By the way, 7-Eleven Japanese company. I just, I was looking it up on Wikipedia this morning. I don't know why, yeah. Yeah, you got that, that good read in the New York Times. Yeah. Do you read that story in the New York Times? Yeah.
是啊。顺便说一句，7-Eleven是日本公司。我只是，我今天早上在维基百科上查的。我不知道为什么，是啊。是啊，你在《纽约时报》上读到了那个好报道。是啊。你读了《纽约时报》那个故事吗？是啊。
We're not changing the subject though, Will here. When was the last time you were incarcerated? Yeah. Who me? Yeah, you. Never. Never. Never once.
我们没换话题，Will在这里。你上次被监禁是什么时候？是啊。谁，我？是啊，你。从来没有。从来没有。一次都没有。
So soft. You're so soft. Too smart. Yeah. Well, I don't know. When is that? You talked my way out of anything. And we've talked our way out of David.
太软弱了。你太软弱了。太聪明了。是啊。好吧，我不知道。什么时候？你用言语摆脱了任何事。我们已经摆脱了David。
David, we've taken out way too much of your time. Dude, thank you for doing this. Oh man, absolutely. If anything, if nothing else has reminded me, how much I miss hanging out with you. Yeah, come on. I miss you guys too. I really do.
David，我们占用了你太多时间了。伙计，谢谢你做这些。哦，天哪，绝对的。如果说有什么的话，如果没别的，这提醒了我，我有多想和你们一起聚聚。是啊，得了吧。我也想你们。我真的想。
Sean, not so much, but you guys. Sure. And it's very good to see you. Very good to hear your voices and you too, man. Thank you for being here, David. Love you, David Cross. Love you, David. You're the best, pal.
Sean，没那么想，但你们。当然。很高兴见到你。很高兴听到你们的声音，你也一样，伙计。谢谢你来，David。爱你，David Cross。爱你，David。你是最棒的，伙计。
This is a blast. Very good to see you. Sean, Jason, Will, Will, Will. All right. So I just leave, right? Yeah, you just leave. And that's it. It's just over.
这太棒了。很高兴见到你。Sean，Jason，Will，Will，Will。好吧。所以我现在就走，对吧？是啊，你就走吧。就这样。结束了。
OK, man. Thank you guys. Thanks, David. Bye, pal. Strangers, don't be strangers. We won't see you guys. Bye, buddy. He's the best.
好的，伙计。谢谢你们。谢谢，David。再见，伙计。陌生人，别做陌生人。我们不会见你们的。再见，伙计。他是最棒的。
I mean, it really was just a perfect blend of people on that set and that cast. He's got such a unique space there. And, God, I really, really miss listening to him. Same here. I always felt like he really, he's one of those, you know, when you play, like if you play somebody in a tennis or you play whatever with somebody who's better than you,
我是说，那个片场和那个演员阵容真的是完美融合。他在那里有这样一个独特的空间。而且，天哪，我真的，真的非常想念听他说话。我也是。我一直觉得他真的，他是那种，你知道，当你打球时，比如如果你和比你强的人打网球或打什么球，
it ups your game. And I always felt that way with David. Like I felt like he just always upped the game in every scene. He's so committed. And sometimes he would come in and be so committed as Tobias. His delivery is so fucking funny and dry. So fucking good. He's so clearly not concerned with, and I don't,
这会提升你的水平。我一直对David有这种感觉。我觉得他在每一场戏里都提升了水平。他太投入了。有时他会进来，作为Tobias表现得如此投入。他的表演太他妈有趣和干练了。太他妈棒了。他显然一点也不关心，我不认为，
he doesn't mean this, I don't think, in an obstinate way. But like, I think he genuinely doesn't care what people think in the best sense of the, you know, he's really brave and unique with his, as you said, with his comedic deliveries, with the way in which he conducts a conversation, with the people he chooses to hang out with. He's completely self-sufficient. And I did admire that a lot when we were working together.
他不是这个意思，我不觉得，是以一种固执的方式。但就像，我觉得他真的不在乎别人怎么想，从最好的意义上说，你知道，他真的很勇敢，很独特，正如你所说，他的喜剧表演，他进行对话的方式，他选择交往的人。他是完全自给自足的。我们一起工作时我真的很钦佩这一点。
I was just reminded by it. And I think that also he's got that thing where he is, you know, his comedy is so funny. It can be kind of a cervic and it can be sometimes almost feel controversial. But he is, as Jason will tell you, he's very sweet. He's such a sweet guy. And the more you get to know him,
我刚才被提醒了。而且我觉得他还有那种特质，就是，你知道，他的喜剧太搞笑了。它可以有点尖刻，有时甚至会让人觉得有争议。但他，正如Jason会告诉你的，他非常甜。他是个非常甜的人。你越了解他，
there's more to love about him. And what's crazy about the Mr. Show thing, I was thinking like, that they don't own Mr. Show with Bob and David, what, they should just change it to Mr. Show. Bye. Bob and David. Bye.
就越有更多值得爱他的地方。关于《Mr. Show》最疯狂的是，我在想，他们不拥有Bob和David的《Mr. Show》，什么，他们应该把它改成《Mr. Show》。再见。Bob和David。再见。
Bye. That was horrendous. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
再见。那太糟糕了。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。